I am was looking for our trace utility
for Python I didn't see it i saw i
didn't appeal one many years ago and i
actually didn't say to another
programming languages so i was good i
spent a lot of time trying to find Tracy
Tillett in Python and there there
actually wasn't any I until um basically
what you do is you tell you tell the you
say what variables you're going to print
out and then you say trace on at some
point in the code and trace off when you
finish so the strange thing is but in
Python they don't go into great detail
in that this is mostly made for programs
that are complex and basically when you
write a large program you forget what
you are doing and so basically this
allows you to see everything that
happened in the program that you have
okay so
basically what it does is it collects
some or all information on executing
program which is a variable as a
function named the line number is the
source code python is a lot of
introspection so so and those are lots
of stuff you can store so basically it
stores it also story and this is supper
called it also stories output from
French state print statements and any
terminating execution that the trace
backs and then you play back the file
okay so it can also so you can also stop
execution say let's say you're an
infinite loop and there's too many lines
too much time or actually the original I
called PI trades monitor was because I
was hoping I could sort of stop it but I
can't i canna as I say later on i'm
using sis not set trace which is a part
of sis which is a sea program which I
don't feel like modifying okay so then
the other obvious thing is you don't
know where the pro game is it should sit
certain learning so basically you can
dump this out on the screen or cellular
network you can set breakpoints and you
know basic something like breakpoints
and then look at all so well actually I
don't remember this I like run
automatically every time the function is
executed all of them say out what I
meant was that I can set this up so that
I don't have to say trace on tour so if
it just starts okay so other the
abilities are you want to what your
reference counts are you want to know
what the ids are left for example does
the object make some refer to wrong
average this basically stuff that's
being
in a file determining herons path of
class at determine if there's a conflict
of methods include and basically since
these are test you should include
everything if the code the documentation
the trace and the configuration in one
file and then this is a bit or you can
go back and look at it okay so the
output is so that the basic
configuration is local variables the
current function name the line number
and the source go at the line so the
current function name i'm sorry i
basically I you have to give it a
function it doesn't if you don't give it
a function it doesn't it doesn't work it
just starts tracing on the on a function
okay so this is some our program so it
is a very small program so so I'm saying
upward Jane range 30 then I'm
incrementing w by 2 okay so then i say i
create a function here i actually don't
have to do all those but ok a function
here which is basically it excludes the
function so I said trace on then I
function name of trace off okay so the
output is basically a dictionary and
addiction areas so basically the analyze
that control is the analyze program so
basically the local variables here are
J&W the file name is test1 dot pie that
the code was for I in the event type is
a line and the function name is T so
basically this use assistant set trace
as I say there's the only thing I could
find and unless I went to lower levels
and I think when you get too low levels
and python that there's very little
documentation the output is pickled okay
and you should be able to so basically
classes do not work in plate responded
by itself I think that's because bright
classes are acts and a down to python
and not an integral part of python okay
so this basically since using low level
functionality this will not work in this
works at the only a Python prompt which
you you basically get into your
operating system they say python that to
the ordinary port right but it doesn't
work in ipython be Python idle wing IDE
so basically in order to run it inside
one of these things you can spawn a
process and run it in in that process
okay so basically as I said that the
function name is tracer sister cetera is
called tracer and then start with
started on um okay so um so there's
different basically if you look in
inspect you'll see a bunch of event
types so the event types is lines the
basic line will give you the most
information as exception call return
another so I spent most of my time a
line i'm not sure what call and return
would would help out okay so so this is
the inspect module and so
this is basically are just a portion of
the code I try to put everything
together here so essentially so you get
get frame info from your frame and then
you then you say if they're the file
name line number so on then it that puts
it into the basically puts it into a
dictionary which is a flame info dot out
okay so I never to stop things from
being pickled in order to stop them for
a mom so when things are being pickled
and to stop them that and to stop them
from a boy basically to explode values
and include this included types and
instituted types so basically this is
just part of the filter pie so basically
before you pickle at you you be careful
what you what you store also in tracer
there is a there is there's a test to
see if it can be pickled or not so
basically a thing distant crash because
there's a type in there that that can't
be pickled okay so so they so basically
the there's a configuration file and so
in this case we have max lines 1,000
lines next time so basically you don't
want to run into an infinite loop and
then this is the results files pickle
and then we've got so basically frame I
want filename line of our function name
line code and local variable analyze
basically analyze file or print so right
now I haven't done a lot with that
basically just dumps out what's in there
ok so this I claim this replace places a
lot of debugging tools one of the step
debugger step debugger doesn't provide
you with very much information
and this provides you with everything
Stephanie burger what I provided you
tell it enough give it enough things
logging modules unit test and execution
profiler execution profiler are
basically what you have is there's
overhead obviously with the tracer
routine but to a certain extent if you
take that overhead into account you can
do you can sort of calculate what times
other times that year your program
itself is taking coverage pi coverage at
pi is the program which shows you what
code was covered in what wasn't so this
can function as coverage pi this an also
determine memory usage heap pi so
basically determining memory at any lie
on the program that's obviously also
overhead with the tracery routine ok so
my way it is on pike ice blended at
googlecode com I have a new version
which haven't put up there yet I in the
past I in the past I did not put up
enough documentation something to put a
lot more documentation up there I've
actually my new version i have added
functionality to it I was actually
hoping a lot of people would get
involved in this and keep adding to it I
think with introspection in Python
probably a lot more things could be
added so i will also put a repository a
code repository i think on google code
you use mercurial any but i think github
seems to be the main one so so basically
my my original hope was that since this
is this is a rather big project I was
hoping other people would get involved
and had
to what I've done obviously I need to do
far more documentation that I've already
done so that's all thank you